i gotta admit
given what we've seen over the last six
months i thought we were witnessing the
end of the division franchise
but then suddenly out of the blue today
or tomorrow depending on when i actually
managed to release this we receive an
announcement from ubisoft
saying that not only is the division
going to be hanging around but it will
be expanding
into what they are calling a division
universe
this isn't just an update to the
division 2 but a separate standalone
addition to the world
ubisoft released an update on social
media discussing their new title
the division heartland
[Music]
i won't read through the article word
for word i just want to talk to some of
the points they've raised
mainly because i'm bloody excited and
feel the need to talk to it
but i have a link to the original story
in the description
they started out by talking around the
high ambitions they still have around
the division ip
that the success around the title has
led to a community of over 40 million
players
and that this had set up the franchise
to move on a trajectory that would
include more games
and more transmedia content set within
the division universe
now we already know of the new content
being created for the division 2
hopefully later on this year
but there has been other ubisoft teams
exploring additional ways to introduce
the division to even more players
and this is where the concept behind the
division heartland grew from
heartland is a free-to-play game set in
the division universe
being developed by redstorm studio they
went on to say that heartland
is a standalone game that doesn't
require previous experience within the
series
but will provide an all-new perspective
on the universe in a new setting
so no previous experience in the
franchise is required
it will provide an all-new perspective
and it's free to play
details are particularly slim but even
with the small amount of information
we've received so
far we can speculate because that seems
to be what we do here
are they following the now dated trend
of creating a battle royale
the development has been led by redstorm
entertainment a studio with close ties
to the tom clancy licenses
who have also worked on the division and
the division two
redstone does have a history of working
on the division pvp in earlier days
and this would certainly make the pvp
crowd happy maybe it will be a spin-off
of the survival mode
this has certainly been something the
community has been most disappointed
about
and not seeing the continuation of will
it be a looter shooter
and skill based or maybe we'll be seeing
some sort of large-scale mmo
or a single-player story narrative as
was talked about quite some time ago by
one of the divs
will this new game even be canon
continuing with the story
or branching off in some sort of way
based on the name of the game and the
image alone with the large water tower
overlooking a landscape
of low flat rolling terrain it wouldn't
be unreasonable to assume that heartland
will be based in the american midwest
the kenaid and fellow division addict
maverick
not only pointed out that michigan is in
this region of the us and that this is
the location of the events that took
place at the end of the broken door
novel with april kalahar
she even points out that ann arbor also
has a large water tower
overlooking the settlement
but i would be surprised if it was a
game with a full-on campaign
like we've seen from the other two
whatever they're planning
i expect there'll be continued focus on
the core of what the division is
being one of the major early entries
into the luda shooter genre
i don't think we'll be seeing a
dedicated battle royale pvp mode of the
game
this isn't what the division is known
for where the story
gameplay and pve elements have been what
has driven the franchise
and the bulk of the player base up until
now sorry pvp players i could be wrong
but it just doesn't make sense to me
however there are rumors that this is
the reason that we never saw survival
make it into the second game
regardless of the direction heartland is
set to release in 2021 2022
on pc and console however you can sign
up for early testing now so hopefully
we'll get to see something soon
i'm obviously very excited to see that
division is not just still being worked
on
but has another standalone game coming
out though as it's a free-to-play game
i'm interested to see how their
monetization model will work
but heartland wasn't the only new
development in the tom clancy universe
they also talked about a division mobile
game coming out
i'm not necessarily much of a mobile
gamer but the increase in audience and
awareness of the division name
certainly won't be a bad thing for its
future and as well as the movie that's
currently being created
we'll also be getting a new original
novel
so what is to come for the franchise
updates to the division 2
with emphasis on a new method for
levelling agents and an increase in
build variety and viability
a movie a novel and a new free-to-play
game
called heartland i think it's pretty
safe to say that the division isn't
dying
and in fact is setting up for a long
future in the industry
as i said i'll post a link to the full
article in the description
hopefully you're as happy as i am to see
some sort of a future for the division
and if you're not you're absolutely
watching the wrong videos
anyway thanks for watching and i'll
catch you in the next one cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
uh